cinquante postes en cdi et aucun cv dans
la boîte aux lettres stéphane pozzo bon
imaginez sûrement croulé sous les
demandes
lorsqu'il a récemment décidé de produire
une fraise 100% française dans une
nouvelle serre pourtant malgré une large
communication
il n'a reçu aucune candidature il
pourrait faciliter sa situation en
engageant des travailleurs détachés mais
cet agriculteur ne le souhaite a
aujourd'hui une partie du personnel bien
de l'étranger et notamment via des
contrats omi qui donne des contrats omi
c'est des contrats de travail heures qui
viennent
hors espace schengen et dessus c'est de
l'esclavagisme moderne
ces pauvres jeunes donc déjà sommes
obligés de payer aux pacers une certaine
somme qui après chez certains patrons
indélicats et surveiller bien en dessous
du smic
et aujourd'hui ça me fait de la
concurrence déloyale même même si on
essaye nous nous placer avec notre
personnel sur une autre une autre ligne
dans l'agriculture
la plupart des exploitations emploient
de la main d'oeuvre étrangère pour
limiter les coûts mais aussi pour
embaucher plus facilement on a quand
même certaines certains personnels
français qui travaillent en effet avec
travail dans la culture et qui ne sont
pas mécontents mais une grosse partie ne
veulent pas venir travailler dans les
champs ou là mais c'est tout simplement
parce qu'on a toujours eu un problème et
c'est un problème général
le gars qui est au chômage un ils
préfèrent rester au chômage a touché 700
900 euros par mois plutôt que de gagner
300 euros de plus être fixée c'est si
nous causé ces général c'est paco la
couture en soit une centaine de
personnes travaillent aujourd'hui pour
stéphane mais ce n'est pas suffisant
même si la tendance penche vers la
consommation 100% française et que ses
barquettes pourrait trouver leurs
acheteurs encore faut-il que tout les
fraises puisse être récoltés